grandma God indefinitely detain now
trying to come visit Christmas Eve you
could claim she had a right to counsel
but some folks in the Congress disagree
she was flying home to our house when
she got stopped by TSA thought she might
be up to holla when they had a look at
grandma's old x-ray her hair had
recently been colored she paid cash for
Christmas gifts two things apparently
the Congress has determined might make
you a terrorist grandpa got indefinitely
detained now trying to come visit
Christmas Eve
they took her rights in order to protect
her rights the most genius plan ever in
history let's see we need to have these
powers to help protect this free country
but if it takes these steps to do so
what is it exactly we are protecting now
she's an enemy combatant as if that
makes any sense the only thing that
she's combating is her unpredictable
incontinence grandma got a definitely
detained now trying to come visit
Christmas Eve you can claim there's no
right to due process but check the Fifth
Amendment and you'll see grandma God is
definitely detained now everybody never
made it home on Christmas Day she always
wanted to live in Miami
at least now she's just 90 miles away
[Music]
Merry Christmas
you